so I'm delighted to be here with you
this afternoon and what I thought I
would do is just give you a very brief
update on eBay the company has changed
dramatically since I did my last view
from the top which I was just talking to
Dean Joss I think was five years ago and
just so will do a quick update and then
a few lessons learned from being at the
helm of eBay for nearly eight and a half
years and then open it up to your
question and answers I'm also joined
here today by Jeff Jordan Jeff you can
stand up Jeff is president of PayPal and
a GSB alumni
I decided I couldn't come alone to the
GSB without bringing a fella a GSB
person to run interference for me so as
you think about it eBay has evolved from
in 1995 a us only collectibles website
when I joined the company eight percent
of the items on eBay were actually
beanie babies
you know those soft little toys this was
not in fact we widely shared with
investors but between 1995 and 1998
actually the company evolved and by 1999
the community of users had taken us
beyond collectibles to consumer
electronics to all kinds of different
categories and also in 1999 we decided
to take the company global and I think
in one of our best decisions I had some
advice early on that if you're gonna go
global go soon and go fast and so in
1999 we launched eBay Co UK bought a
company called the Londo which is now
eBay Germany and began to build our
international presence and the first
clue was that there were users who were
using ebay.com from 200 countries and
this was a clue that maybe this concept
was going to be as relevant in Argentina
as it was in Germany as it was in China
so we went global quite early and you
can see that the company was beginning
to change pretty fast
it wasn't until 2000 that we actually
introduced fixed-price and eBay stores
and you might find that a little unusual
because up until that time either was
auction only and if you think about it
we actually taught average people to do
business in an auction format when most
people had only done business at a
Sotheby's or Christie's
and that was the rarefied air of
consumers around the world in 2002 we
made one of the smartest moves we've
ever made which was the acquisition of
PayPal and I'll talk more about that in
a minute but fundamentally PayPal had
become the wallet on eBay and we had to
own that company and then the last two
years we've created other marketplaces
we are now the largest c2c classified
site in the world anchored by our 25%
interest in Craigslist and we acquired
shopping.com last year in addition we
acquired skype last year and I'm gonna
talk a lot about Skype and I'm sure you
have some question
about Skype but I think if you sort of
step all the way back and say what's
been going on at the company for the
last eight years the common theme is
about expanding our vision expanding our
market and expanding our opportunity
so this eBay eBay idea that Pierre
Omidyar founded on Labor Day of 1995
turns out this was a really good idea
back in 1998 there are about a hundred
and fifty thousand users of the site we
ended q1 with one hundred and ninety
three million users if we were a country
we'd be the fifth most populous nation
in the world our users listed in the
quarter five hundred and seventy five
million items for sale so eighty nine
million items are up for sale at any
given point in time six million new
items a day in more than 50,000
categories around the world those use
those listings translated into gross
merchandise volume of 12.5 billion in
the quarter most recently ended or a
fifty billion dollar annualized run rate
for perspective that's 139 million a day
and my personal favorite one thousand
six hundred and eight dollars a second
of gross merchandise volume so while I'm
speaking every second thousand six
hundred and eight dollars a volume of
growth of the the price of the items
going through the site is just
remarkable and I think if you ask people
and say what's the most remarkable thing
about eBay it is that a virtual
marketplace could could actually support
this kind of gross merchandise volume so
for perspective a couch sells every four
minutes in Germany a watch is sold every
three minutes in Italy a collectible
sold every minute in China and a car is
sold every minute in the United States
if we were a retailer which of course
were not we would be the 11th largest
retailer in the world based on actually
last year's gross merchandise volume of
44 billion at 50 billion we would have
just passed Sears on our way to target
so again underscoring just the enormous
power of this virtual marketplace we are
global today we operate in 33 or 34
regions around the world the green there
shows our equity interest in mikado
Libre which is the largest eBay like
trading community in Latin America and a
fun little story founded by
GSB graduates who saw eBay's success and
said I'd like to take this email you're
like trading community back to Latin
America there was a Harvard Business
School group who founded a competing
site called the or Devante and the long
and short of it is the Stanford group
one I hate to tell you that but they
bought out diamante last year last year
we also decided to augment our ebay
trading community with the largest
online shopping comparison site called
shopping comm it's now a top 10 global
e-commerce destination 40 million
uniques per month globally 40 million
product category hundred and 25
categories and more than 8,000 global
merchants served in 2005 so what this
does for us is it allows us to tap a new
in season product for internet shoppers
and what typically shopping comm does is
they serve as brand-name merchants that
you would know Circuit City best by
Sears Nordstrom's are all selling
products on the Shopping comm
marketplace and then last but not least
in the last 12 months we've put together
the number one or number two position in
classifieds in the c2c classified site
around the world in 12 short months
we're in 21 countries and 400 cities
with effectively a Craigslist like
product we launched it from start under
the Kijiji brand name outside the United
States and made several acquisitions
that now put us in a really strong
strategic position and I can tell you
we're glad that we're not starting this
today that we are you know staked out
way ahead in today's world let me turn
to PayPal PayPal vision is to be the
world's online payment standard as I
mentioned we acquired the company in
2002 after a fairly interesting
interaction with PayPal they had become
the wallet on eBay and we woke up one
day to see that 20% of all listings
offered PayPal we had a competing
product called bill point which PayPal
was crushing so we entered into a series
of negotiations with the PayPal team and
they started out and said we want five
hundred for the company we said three
hundred two months later weary engaged
they said 700 we said 500 they said a
billion we said eight six months later
they said a billion - we said a billion
a year later they said a billion five is
it fine
it was we chased them all the way up and
the reason is they continued to execute
and we are the reason that they were
successful was eBay was the host of the
largest person-to-person payment system
because eBay was the locus and host of
the largest conglomeration of small
businesses and without eBay PayPal never
would have been able to get started
PayPal is doing really well as well
PayPal passed 105 million accounts
available now in 55 markets around the
world PayPal now actually has more
accounts than American Express and
Discover and more accounts than Bank of
America Wells Fargo Bank dontcha Bank
and Bank of England combined PayPal is
processing 8.8 billion dollars worth of
total payment volume again 97 million
dollars a day or one thousand one
hundred and twenty seven dollars a
second see this is how we measure
ourselves and not only is PayPal
successful on eBay PayPal has built a
successful off eBay business and there's
now a mark or the sole payments provider
for a lot of these industry leaders so
interestingly enough in a funny way
PayPal's opportunity off eBay to be the
online payment standard maybe bigger
than on eBay because as much as I hate
to say it there's more ecommerce that
takes place off eBay than on and PayPal
can be the online payments provider for
every merchant whether you sell on eBay
or not Skype so as I said we acquired
Skype in October of last year and what
Skype does is enable the world's
conversations and I think most of you
know Skype if you don't please leave
here and go sign up and what it allows
you to do is make voice calls over the
internet if I call another Skype user
that call is free if I call a regular
landline or a cell phone line then I pay
a small per minute fee to connect to any
place in the overall telephony network
Skype also has grown really fast it has
a pattern that we recognize really well
that more buyers bring more sellers who
bring more buyers more merchants who
accept paypal bring more buyers who
accept paypal bring more sellers to
accept paypal the more skype users there
are they bring their friends and family
who bring their friends and family who
bring their friends and families so what
we think about the
is really three Network effects
businesses and we think were the world's
leader in understanding the power of
network effects businesses and I think
we understood what Skype offered far
faster than almost anyone else
Skype ended q1 of 2006 with ninety four
point six million users but in May past
the hundred use and 100 million user
mark Skype is adding new registered
users at two hundred and twenty thousand
new users a day I was with the Financial
Times in London and he interviewed me
and I said we're adding two hundred
twenty five thousand and new users a day
in the article was two hundred and
twenty thousand new users a month
because I think he just couldn't
understand how anything could be adding
two hundred and twenty thousand new
users a day there's five hundred
thousand downloads of the software
program every day as people upgrade from
spec 1.0 to 1.5 to 2.5 and interestingly
enough Skype in the first quarter served
six point nine billion minutes and you
can see how fast this is grown and
because skypes leading market is Europe
it's a little more seasonal so what you
see is the q2 q3 summer seasonality out
of fact people come back to school and
in the first quarter
talking again it is truly a global
community there is a Skype user in every
single country of the world the only
country we can't find a user in is North
Korea and there's unparalleled vibrancy
in the marketplace there's over six
million concurrent users of Skype at
prime time over a hundred and twenty
thousand simultaneous calls being made
ninety thousand queries a second on the
network and interestingly enough 7% of
all international long-distance minutes
are now being made on skype but these
three businesses are interesting they
are far more interesting in combination
and we are really working now on a
strategy of what we call the power of
three how do we build three fantastic
standalone businesses but how do we
marry these businesses so that one plus
one plus one equals more than three and
our best example of course is eBay and
PayPal eBay helped PayPal get started
PayPal reduced friction in the eBay
marketplace so you could trade more
rapidly
and more safely at at the same time eBay
helped PayPal gain scale so we're now
got three we think quite interesting
assets that can help each other grow
faster while at the same time continuing
to fulfill their own destiny so I've
been at eBay as as well the in my
introduction said for eight and a half
years I came to eBay when we had just
finished a year where the company did
four point seven million dollars in
revenue this year we should do between
five point seven and five point nine
billion dollars we have 30 employees
today we have over 13,000 we used to be
in just the United States with a US only
website today we operate in 33 countries
and 53 locations so this has been a
remarkable management development and
growth experience because what you need
to do when you're managing a start-up is
different than what I need to do today
with truly you know a global very large
company so as I step back and said you
know what was sure the lessons learned
here the user experience is everything
so it all begins and ends with the
quality of that user experience whether
it's eBay whether it's Skype whether
it's PayPal the user experience is the
major thing that matters in a funny kind
of way Skype re-educated us about this
because Skype is truly a gifted product
company the founders at Skype are the
most gifted product executives I've ever
met and as we got as we you know bought
the company an integrated Skype we began
to you know relearn that lesson again
about the product experience focus focus
focus clear strategic direction is
central at eBay the art of strategy is
in many ways more about the art of
exclusion what are you not going to do
because we have so many opportunities
and today we can cope with many more of
them than we could when we were a little
company but I believe it's far better to
do a small number of things well than a
large number of things sort of 80%
because the devil is in the detail and I
think organizations have only a certain
amount of capability to deliver results
consistently and turn ideas into
businesses with consistency
if there's some focus focus focus the
other thing I've learned is anticipate
anticipate anticipate particularly in
the internet space this thing changes at
the speed of light you know what didn't
even appear to be an issue on the
horizon eight months ago could be a big
big issue today so the ability to see
ahead to anticipate what could happen I
think is a really important skill that
we learned as a company the price of
inaction is far greater than the cost of
a mistake
so inaction deciding not to do anything
is actually a strategy it's a bad
strategy in our world because doing
nothing almost by definition means
you're gonna be falling behind and so
far better to make a mistake and fix it
really fast then be sort of paralyzed by
an array of options and not knowing what
to do so we have a culture where we make
mistakes we make them all the time and
the key is how do you fix how do you
recognize you've made a mistake and fix
it really fast hire an A+ team don't
settle for any - I'm sure you've heard
that in you know the businesses that
you've worked in and at Stanford it's
all about the people the right people in
the right job with the right behaviors
at the right time and this is the key at
a company like eBay is the right time
because someone who seemed so perfect
for a role two years ago by definition
the magnitude of the responsibility has
tripled or doubled or quadrupled in a
year-long period and you just have to
make sure that you continue to have the
right person in the right job at the
right time with the right behaviors
experience and intuition actually
matters a lot in our business you know I
know that when I graduated from Harvard
Business School I wasn't so sure that
experience mattered that much I figured
you could analyze your way out of most
any problem and that you know sometimes
the the oldsters would you know you'd
say gosh you know they don't actually
really get it and now that I'm an old
ster I will tell you that experience and
intuition having seen the movie before
having seen the patterns before pattern
recognition is gained through experience
you can't analyze your way into pattern
recognition
and I think it's incredibly important to
understand that pattern recognition over
the long period of time is important
speed and nimbleness is critical
especially when you get big the
challenge we have today is how do you
grow big and stay small and then finally
execute with integrity and confidence
you know once we decide to do something
at eBay we join hands and we say we're
gonna do that and we're gonna make it as
successful as we can and you have to
execute with confidence believing that
what you've decided to do will work and
then finally culture is critical mission
motivates and our purpose which is as a
company is to you know empower people to
be successful doing what they love the
fact that we have over a million
entrepreneurs making their living
selling full-time on eBay
we have empowered a huge number of
people to be successful doing what they
love and that's a great job to get up to
every morning
last slide people ask me what my
personal philosophy is all the time and
I learned this one from AG Lafley who is
the CEO of Procter & Gamble on whose
board I sit and I think is one of the
most talented CEOs in America and his
first lesson that he always talks about
is know thyself be thyself know who you
are know what your strengths and
weaknesses are and be yourself you have
to be who you are
authenticity the ability to be to
pretend that you're someone else is not
sustainable to be to pretend you're good
at something you're not at it's not
sustainable smart organizations will
figure that out and so I think this
whole notion of know yourself and be
yourself is incredibly important do
something you really like with people
you really enjoy face it I spend more
time with Jeff Jordan practically than I
do with my husband
so we better get a lock and it has to be
fun you know you have to be able to
laugh at yourself and you know really
have a good time when you're at work
deliver the business and financial
results you know it all starts with
execution people say gee you know mag
how have you been successful in business
it's cuz whatever job I was given in the
early days I executed like mad I said I
am gonna be the best at whatever job I
was assigned to do when I joined Procter
and Gamble I told this story I came out
of Harvard Business School and the
assignment I had was to determine what
size the hole in the ivory shampoo
shampoo cap should be should it be
three-eighths of an inch or four eighths
of an inch I was like wait a minute I
just graduated from Harvard Business
School I'm not figuring out how big the
hole in the shampoo cap could be and it
wasn't quite what I had in mind you know
I thought like I would have a bigger job
and but it was really clear that was
what my first assignment was and I
decided I was gonna do the very best job
that had ever been done at the Procter &
Gamble Company to figure out what size
this whole mission puka thought to be
and you know it's just stood me in good
stead you just deliver the results as
very best you can over the long haul as
I said mistakes are okay just fix them
fast and I think one of the things we do
well at eBay is we recognize when we
make mistakes and a lot of companies
stand on ego so we bought a company
called butter fields and butter fields
and cruise you know big mistake we
figured it out and we sold them we sold
them both at a loss but far better to
move on get them out of the portfolio
and stop the management drag than stand
on ceremony and ego about how it would
be that you maybe couldn't admit you'd
made a mistake codify the lessons
learned from every experience I have a
little notebook that once a week I write
a few things I learned that week and
it's fascinating to go back and look
over the years because sometimes you
forget what you already knew and just
the discipline of trying to codify the
lessons is very is useful build a great
team and share credit liberally be fun
to work with don't be afraid to ask what
you don't know or understand when I came
to eBay I didn't know a lot about the
internet I didn't know a lot about the
technology that ran the site and I asked
a million questions sometimes too a lot
of pushback
and particularly the engineers in the
early days I think we're a little bit
like this woman knows nothing about
technology and now I know a lot about
technology so you just have to be not
afraid to ask what you don't know and
then finally stating the obvious never
compromise your integrity that's what
you have at the end of the day no one
can take that from you and in today's
world I think it's a really really
important thing perhaps more important
than ever so with that why don't we turn
to some questions yeah
yeah in a funny kind of way I think some
of the tenants of management whether
you're in a small company or a big
company whether you're in the apparel
and shoe industry or whether you're in
the internet industry are really similar
you know it's focus focus focus it's
hiring the right people and the right
job it's having the right strategy those
are some of the real tenants but I will
tell you when I came to eBay I did
something really smart and this is
because I did it wrong at an earlier
company when I came to eBay clearly
things were going pretty well my first
month on the job the compound monthly
growth rate was 70% and so what I did
when I first got there is try to figure
out what was going right the tendency
when you come in from the outside is to
prove yourself by finding what's going
wrong let's fix this and this and this
and this actually entering into an
organization and finding what's right is
incredibly powerful and that's the best
way to integrate yourself into the
culture is find out what the
organization is doing right it's a
little counterintuitive because you
think well gee maybe they won't think
I'm adding value like because they kind
of know what they're doing right but
actually it really works every time it
gets you a window into the culture that
then allows you over time to begin to
make an imprint and build the
organization in a way that you think you
should
so I'm asked all the time you know how
is the internet industry different than
the Walt Disney Company it's very
different but mostly on the speed we do
more in a week than you know I did at
many of my other companies in a month
six months or a year the speed of
decision making is much more rapid and
you have to be comfortable in a little
bit more of a run-and-gun environment
yeah
main eventing in some of these different
environments giving solar so let's start
with eBay and then I'll talk a little
bit about PayPal it turns out this
concept of connecting people in a global
trading environment across you know
without river where boundaries and time
are not as important is as relevant in
Germany as it is in the United States as
it is in China as it is in Argentina
there are entrepreneurs in every country
of the world who want to be successful
and there are people who are looking to
buy things at a value buy hard-to-find
items and so this model travelled really
really well and we you know what's
interesting about eBay because 98
percent of the site is user-generated
content eBay Germany is instantly German
because all the items are sold by German
sellers and the buyers are Germany and
so it becomes of the national character
almost immediately so the differences
that we see are the types of categories
that are you know big sellers the
category mix is different the average
selling price tends to sometimes be
different the mix of fixed price and
auction tends to be different but the
fundamentals of connecting buyers and
sellers is the same I would say Asia
particularly China Korea and Japan are
actually more different and our model in
Korea and our model in China has evolved
to be more different than the core eBay
than in any of our other markets and
people talk about Asia all the time in
my view there's no Asia Korea is as
different from China as the United
States is from China and yes it's it's
Asian culture but they're very very
different markets and so we've learnt
that over time with PayPal PayPal is
more challenging to move overseas and
the fact that we are in 55 countries is
a huge competitive advantage because
unlike eBay where you just launch a site
in Germany or Argentina and with PayPal
you have to connect into the money
systems in each of those countries
you've got to connect into the banking
system you've got to understand do most
people pay with credit cards or debit
cards do most people pay with EFT or do
they pay with cash in check and so and
then you of course have the legal and
regulatory hurdles that when you're
handling people's money the government
cares a lot
and when we launched in Australia there
was a six-month period of time where
there were three different government
agencies who wanted to regulate PayPal
it was like a regulation frenzy and you
know so there's just tremendous legal
and regulatory issues that you have to
abide by to be successful in each
country so eBay is quite easy to extend
internationally PayPal much more
difficult Skype is instantaneously
international right
we actually have users when we acquired
Skype they had no people in the United
States there were no Skype employees in
the United States and yet one of the
fastest-growing markets so Skype is
perhaps our most global business that
doesn't actually have a locus in in
terms of where you would say Skype
actually starts yeah so I think it
varies by country and it varies by
business I think the the sort of feeling
about eBay in some ways which is so at
odds with my personal experience as the
DBA has never had any competition you
know I will tell you Jeff and I've been
at eBay for a long time it doesn't feel
like we've never had any competition you
know when we took the company public in
September of 1998
Yahoo launched their auction business on
the second day of the IPO Roadshow we
did a secondary offering where he raised
a billion dollars in March of 1999 on
the second day of that Roadshow Amazon
launched their auction business my
conclusion was not to do any more
raising of money
because every time I did I drew another
competitor so we have seen competition
over the years I would say today in you
know most of our markets we're seeing
new in season retail grow rapidly and
we're finally seeing the bricks and
clicks getting their act together you
know whether it's gap calm or Walmart
calm or target calm or Carrefour calm
you know in I remember thinking in 1999
gee these bricks-and-mortar players
ought to be very formidable competitors
because think about you can buy online
or turn lambaste you know you can do
lots of comparing and they are finally
you know actually Walmart calm is doing
quite well and I think you know we're
gonna have to query ahac impede much
more aggressively with land-based
retailers who are really doing well now
online there's also some pure plays that
are emerging like huzzah post calm here
in the United States and so in every
country in the world we see different
competitors I think Google is a
competitor you know we haven't seen much
traction in Google base we haven't seen
much traction in Google pay but clearly
you know they're interested in what
we're doing and I think we have to be
thoughtful about that with regards to
PayPal PayPal you know was very unique
and basically enabled a way for people
who had an email account to send or
receive money and interestingly we faced
Citibank launched a product called c2 it
Western Union offered a product Yahoo
offered their own product and actually
we believe we have a huge lead in that
business that it's going to be very hard
for someone to catch up that said I
think every financial institution
ultimately will be very interested in
getting into this business because when
you're processing 8.8 billion dollars of
total payment volume and a quarter it
makes you one of the largest payment
processors in the United States so I
think we're gonna see more competition
with regard to Skype everyone's in that
market and again I think what people
didn't understand about the Skype
acquisition is how far Skype was ahead
it's interesting that Skype adds vanagas
entire installed base every week so we
have just an enormous lead that I don't
think is well appreciated that said
Google talks in it Yahoo my
core soft you know most cable companies
are getting into this business most
phone companies are getting into the
business so I think it's going to be
really competitive why don't we go all
the way in the back yeah so obviously
success has made a number of eBay
employees early ones in yourself
included
very very financially successful so two
questions how much do you worry about
attrition from these folks as a result
of the lack of meaningful financial
motivation and what do you do to keep
them motivated and second what is it
personally that is still motivating you
to keep growing eBay and making it
successful so it's interesting
eBay you know has gone through sort of
an evolution over the last eight years
obviously because we've gone from a
relatively small number of employees to
a large number of employees and over
time some of those pre-ipo employees
some of those early employees have left
you know many people said gosh I made
more money than I ever dreamed I would
and really what I wanted to be was a
poet or I wanted to build houses or I
wanted to be an architect or I wanted to
be a teacher and I never thought I would
have that opportunity so there have
there have been some very good people
who have left and I think that's the
natural course of things and as long as
they're going on to do something that
they love you know I think that's okay
that said the vast majority of people
have stayed and you know it's because I
think first of all we try to do a good
job in helping people develop their own
career interests and whether that's you
know Jeff Jordan started working with us
when he ran the regionals business then
he ran eBay us and then we moved him
over to round PayPal and I think that
was interesting and Jeff can speak for
mousse out for himself but it was
interesting because it was a whole new
skill set a whole new industry a company
if you will or a division at a very
different stage of growth so what we try
to do is give people what we call a
career adventure that if you stay too
long in the very same job there's good
news about that because you get expert
power but also maybe you're not as
stimulated and is interested so I think
we have an obligation to people to keep
moving people around and giving them a
variety of experiences I would say the
other thing that people stay to die for
is truly the purpose you know this
notion of being able to empower a
million people to make their living
they take payments with paypal and call
their customers with Skype it's really
pretty remarkable not that very minute
not many companies have that direct
tangible social benefit that we happen
to have as a byproduct of our business
model with regard to myself you know
what eBay is endlessly interesting I
would say every week there's a new
challenge a new set of issues and I
learned something almost every day and
it is a fascinating place to be and to
watch and help this company grow up is
remarkably interesting and you know so
that's why I do it and obviously you
know it's not obviously for the money at
this point it's for the fun for the
enjoyment for the camaraderie and for
you know just you got to work every day
and you go and you know what this is
really interesting and really fun yeah
there are two interesting business
sectors if you will developing on the
internet now that you can one is
person-to-person lending with companies
like sofa and prosper and the other is
site independent ratings like raptly
yeah which are surely very interesting
flavor yeah so the person-to-person
lending sites are interesting to us
actually founded by people we know well
funded by benchmark that obviously was
the original Thunder found venture
capital behind eBay so we're watching
them with great interest and actually
you know theoretically is quite a
natural extension of PayPal right
because PayPal has financial
relationships now with a hundred and
five million accounts and what you know
what we know is that if you have a
broader financial relationship with us
you tend to do more business with us so
we're watching it with great interest
and it'll be fascinating to see how much
traction these companies get what's
interesting about eBay at this juncture
is we certainly still are in the mode of
planting acorns before we need oak trees
meaning you can start with a little
business but ultimately to make a
difference now we need to have
billion-dollar businesses and so what I
want to make sure of is how big how much
scale and mass there actually is behind
a notion of a p2p lending opportunity
with regard to reputation on the net
I think we actually have a really
interesting opportunity we have the
biggest reputation system on the net by
a huge order of magnitude billions and
billions of feedback have been left for
our buyers and our sellers and the
question now is do we decouple that from
our core eBay business and think about
how we provide a reputational system on
the net that may well be combined with
PayPal which is fast becoming the wallet
on the net and as I said at our Analyst
Day about a week and a half ago I said
it's interesting to think about PayPal
as your wallet eBay as your reputation
Skype is your presence and can we
decouple these and combine them in a way
that actually is some of the key
building blocks of the future of the
internet that will be you know
personalizable customizable and allow
you to assemble assemble those building
blocks in a way that has not been done
before
so we're thinking a lot about how to do
that and how to take Skype presence the
wallet and reputation and think about
combining those in a kind of an
interesting way let's go over here tell
us what was going through your mind did
you know you had a winner on your hands
what made you want to take this
get yourself a mental cutoff system so
is interesting when I first got the
headhunter call interestingly eBay has
been profitable since inception and
Pierre didn't need any venture capital
money in fact the money that benchmark
put in the company effectively is still
in the bank and so he the reason he took
venture capital is he wanted to hire a
CEO and he thought unless he had venture
capital would be sort of hard to be
legitimized or you know a sort of a
legitimate CEO candidate so he hired a
headhunter and I got a call and I they
explained this to me and I said I don't
think so you know I was living in Boston
my husband was running the brain tumor
program at the Mass General I had two
boys who were four and seven and I said
I am NOT moving 3,000 miles across the
country for this no name internet
company forget about it and three here
three months later the headhunter called
me back and said you know what you are
perfect for this company and this
company is perfect for you I beg you to
get on a plane and meet the founder and
to kind of not make the head under mad I
thought I don't definitely do not want
this opportunity but I might want the
next thing he has so okay I will get on
a plane and I'm so the night before I
decide maybe I ought to go to the
website that would probably be a good
idea because I thought okay I'm gonna
have to spend four hours with Pierre it
would be good if I'd been to the website
and I almost didn't get on the plane
because the website had three parts the
first part was eBay which was actually
called auction web the URL was eBay but
the site was called auction web in one
of the great all-time marketing moves we
changed the name of the company to be
the URL
pierre was also completely focused on
the Ebola virus he no I'm not getting
hit a passion for the Ebola virus and so
a third of the site was the Ebola virus
and everything you ever wanted to know
about the Ebola virus and the other
third of the website was Pierre's
fiancees homepage and the site was in
black and white and I'm like this is
insane
I have agreed to fly 3,000 miles across
the country to meet the founder of the
Ebola virus website but I was kind of
embarked so I get on the plane I get out
there the next day I'm thinking okay
like how fast can I get out of here and
I have to tell you the out of the three
hours I spent with Pierre he is a
remarkable individual just a remarkable
individual he was 29 at the time and had
a vision for what this company could
become there are many people who say
they are visionaries and most people are
not Pierre is a visionary and he
actually understood what was going on
here and he told me a couple of facts he
said people can do things they've never
been able to do on ebay they can connect
over space and time and trade with
people that they've never met and
they've made their best friends on eBay
people have connected over a shared area
of interest and what I saw there I have
a belief about brands that there's two
aspects to brands one is allowing you to
do something that you couldn't do before
so in my P&G days whiter whites cleaner
cleans fresher breath in this case in
this case it was about connecting people
in a way they never could be connected
and then there's the emotional
connection to brands and if you have the
features and functionality and you have
the emotional connection you rarely have
both and when you do it can combust and
what I saw in this tiny company and in
Pierre is that he had both so I get back
on the plane I show up at home and I
said to my husband hon I think we
actually ought to move to California so
that I can go work at this company
called eBay because are you insane are
you crazy
and anyway to his credit he decided that
this would be sort of fun and
interesting and I said but you know I'm
not really going if you don't have a job
because it's sort of a problem because
this thing could fail and like we need
to have money and so I said so so he
said well I'll call Gary Steinberg
at Stanford who runs the neurosurgery
program at Stanford and I know he was
hoping that Gary would not have a job so
he calls Gary and the neurosurgery
community is very small there's only
3,000 neurosurgeons in the country and
they all kind of know each other so he
calls Gary Steinberg and goes hi it's
Griff harsh my wife you know would
really like to come out to California to
work for this company that I've never
heard of and you know I was just
wondering if you had a job and I know
Griff was thinking please do my job
please not a job I hear I said actually
I'm opening up a search for the head of
the brain tumor program today would you
like it so it never happens that way
right I mean it never happens and it was
a sign so anyway that's how that's how I
got here and so we were thinking you
know what I think we were thinking
what's the worst thing that can happen
the worst thing that can happen is it
falls apart and I go get another job so
I think that was sort of the point of
view that we had and we I just had an
instinct I had an instinct it would
never have yielded to analysis that this
was the right thing to do just had an
instinct that it was the right thing to
do and I I'm a big believer in following
your instincts and by all rights I mean
I was at Hasbro running the preschool
division Barney
Arthur Teletubbies by all rights I
should have gone to eToys right you know
that would have been a much more logical
extension good thing I didn't do that
yeah
with great difficulty I mean the truth
is it's been a little wild because you
know actually being an academic
neurosurgeon is a big deal and he does
brain tumors so you know he can be in
surgery for 12 14 16 hours at a time so
with a great deal of help and you know
both people that you pay to help you but
you know you're your parents and your
friends and and your siblings the other
thing I would say is that quite early on
I let go of the notion that I could be
the perfect wife the perfect mother the
perfect hostess the perfect CEO
something has to give along the way here
and you know sometimes it's different
things that have to give and sometimes
you have to say you know what I just
cannot do this thing with my family I've
got to do a bay and sometimes you say I
cannot do this eBay thing that must be
done because I've got to you know be at
the fourth-grade soccer game and it's
just about making those trade-offs in a
way that is intelligent and tries to
sort of meet as many people's needs as
you can but I will tell you you know
it's interesting you know my house does
not look like Martha Stewart just left
for a whole variety of reasons but but
you know at some point you you have to
you have to sort of like figure out what
you're gonna do and you know I know that
my son and his friends at Princeton got
a huge I mean he was just screaming he
was laughing so hard because I was the
top of the worst-dressed billionaires
list
and he like calls me up because I cannot
believe this I mean this is just this is
horrible and I said I don't know like
like I mean I wish I could cope but I
can't yeah yeah we always hear about the
importance of building the right team
especially at the early stages of the
company how did you attract the right
people and when you're personally
responsible for a hiring decision how do
you distinguish between the a pluses and
minuses are just interview well so I had
a thesis that I'm not sure I could
completely articulate for you at the
time but I can articulate it today which
is hire ahead of the curve okay so if
you have a sixty million dollar company
or five million dollar company that you
think is going to grow you have got to
hire people who can handle way more
because we were so smart in the early
days because eBay grew to us for the
first five years you know I had run a
six hundred million dollar division so
for the first four or five years it even
actually knew what this was looking like
Brian sweetie it was one of my first
hires who I hired as head of marketing
who'd been a the CMO of Pepsi Gary
Bendre was our first chief financial
officer and I knew I didn't want a
freshman CFO I wanted someone who had
been the CFO of a publicly held company
and he'd been the CFO of the extreme
which he had then sold to Microsoft so
we were really smart in hiring people to
whom the country the company could grow
and by the way that's still true today
interestingly we just hired a new chief
financial officer and because our old
chief financial officer is now the
president of Skype and we had a choice
there were a lot of talented internal
candidates and I made the decision to go
outside because I wanted someone who
could help us grow from you know six
billion to 16 billion from you know a
three divisional company to maybe an
even broader company and so I hired Bob
Swan who had spent 15 years at GE and
it's fascinating because you can see his
impact already you know he's here and
we're gonna grow to him and there is
magic in that if you can get the right
cultural fit and the right expertise so
how do you find the a pluses and the
minuses
I think hiring is an art not a science
and I think you know you're wrong 30% of
the time and the key is to figure that
out fast so you know I just talked to
people about real life experiences and
delve deep into what
they've actually done and keep drilling
until you satisfy themselves you satisfy
yourself that they're actually just not
interviewing well there's actually real
experience and you can tell when you ask
second and third and fourth order
questions whether people have really
done what they say they've done or
they've internalized what they say
they've done so I do
situational interviewing I take a
project I take a thing they've done I
take an industry a company a job and I
just follow that path down and it's not
perfect but it's useful the other thing
that I've learnt to do is we check
references and you learn a lot from that
you really learn a lot and you know you
meet someone and they seem fabulous and
I'm not gonna bother to check the
references I'm sure they're gonna be
great don't ever do that it's really
really important because you can learn a
lot from people's references and they
may be glowing but you may uncover a
weakness that then you can help
compensate for as you staff up the
company way in the back
and I understand that Skype is a great
standalone company every day
and I also understand that there are
some side benefits such as understanding
how network effects work and allowing
your eBay users to communicate with each
other but I was wondering if you talked
a bit more about the strategic rationale
for Skype and eBay being the same
company sure sorry so admittedly the
relationship between eBay and PayPal is
closer in that said as we delved into
Skype and tried to understand besides
being a great business where we thought
the synergies were interestingly and as
we've now own Skype I would say that the
nearest term synergies maybe not the
biggest inner issues but the nearest
term synergies are actually between
PayPal and Skype because if any of you
have used Skype you know that it's
actually a little hard to pay that's not
usually a good thing for a business and
so the PayPal team of the Skype team are
working very hard to seamlessly have
PayPal be the wallet on skype the other
thing that's interesting is they can
help PayPal fight fraud I mean Skype
fight fraud so Skype was almost brought
down as PayPal was almost brought down
by some early fraudulent activity on the
site and PayPal is world class now at
fraud fighting online and so there's a
lot of synergies there and then the
other thing is gee what about these two
hundred and twenty thousand users a day
who are coming to Skype what if all of
those got a PayPal account does that
accelerate PayPal ubiquity on the net
and their ubiquity in terms of being the
online payment standard so near-term
actually interestingly and I'm not sure
we completely understood this at the
acquisition the PayPal Skype synergies
are closer together and I think very
tangible and very real with regard to
eBay what we know on eBay is reducing
friction is hugely important to the
marketplace so when we reduced payment
friction ie you didn't have to pay with
cheques money orders wait for seven days
for the check to clear get the goods
before you were back in the market
removing friction is very very powerful
so we think at high average selling
prices removing communication friction
could be very powerful so if you're
thinking about buying a car you might
really like to talk to the person as
opposed to have an email exchange and
people say well gee aren't you worried
that people will close the transactions
off the marketplace I don't
if it increases the velocity of trade my
viewers will try to figure out how to
monetize that and then there's the
notion of building a paper call model
and enabling us to start some
marketplaces that have not been well
suited to a transaction based revenue
model you'll notice that actually Kars
is the largest category on eBay our
sellers sold over 750,000 used cars on
eBay last year if we are an auto dealer
which were not we would actually be the
largest auto dealer in the world I've
used cars but no one sells new cars on
eBay and you know why because dealers
want you to call the dealership so they
can upsell you cross sell you get you
leather instead of cloth you know the
racing stripe instead of the regular
paint job or whatever and so they don't
want to close that transaction online so
the question is could we create mark
places that are not well suited to a
transaction based revenue model but a
lead generation model and interestingly
Bill Ford sits on our board and when we
were talking about this he said you know
calls come in to Ford headquarters that
we then divert to dealers we charge the
dealer's $15 a call to get that new car
buyer lead so think about services think
about real estate think about new cars
we think this actually can open up a new
set of monetization and marketplace
opportunities for the company yeah
you might have heard can you tell me a
little bit about how you prepare for a
negotiation and what you're like
mr. Jordan is laughing everywhere so
let's see so I will tell you I don't
think I'm a very good negotiator and so
I actually for the first five or six
years at eBay I didn't do it you know I
would be in the background and sort of
advice and counsel but I had some
excellent negotiator Jeff Jordan is one
of our best negotiators best deal guys
in the whole company Mike Jacobson our
general counsel ran the M&A practice for
Cooley Godward here one of the best deal
guys I've seen in the world particularly
when it comes to structuring complex
deals so I think over time what I've
decided is that I actually can intercede
and make sure that people sort of see
the forest from the trees you know do we
want to spin on some notion of five
million dollars or eight million dollars
or two million dollars or do we want to
sort of raise up and say you know in the
grand scheme of things the success or
failure of this deal is not going to be
focused on the last million dollars and
so I think you know eBay is a tough
company to negotiate with but I think
we're actually in some ways you know not
as tough as our reputation I don't know
is interesting or you know in a couple
of deals right now and I think we have
the reputation that we just hammer
people and we were sort of laughing
internally saying if only that were true
so I would say you know I try to sort of
rise above it I try to make sure that
the relationships are right and that we
get through these negotiations with the
relationships intact because in the end
it's actually about the relationships
and the empowerment you know not deals
will be swamped by the execution as
opposed to the deal so one more ok one
more there
yeah so it's the best thing about the
company the fact this community is so
engaged that you can go on the boards
any day and in any given day there's you
know probably thousands of boards with
thousands of posts talking about
everything eBay and everything off eBay
too by the way and we make a mistake or
we do something that the community
doesn't like we know it instantly I mean
I can walk in in the morning and on a
good day I'll have 50 or 60 emails from
our customers when we do something that
really angers them I can have five or
six thousand and our customer support
centers obviously see huge ebbs and
flows in this so it is an immediate
feedback mechanism I think the challenge
around managing this community of users
is you know with 193 million people I
mean you know there are as many users as
there are people it's in some ways and
so what you have to try to do is manage
the marketplace for the good of the
whole and you know that you will never
make everyone happy but if you listen
hard try to understand the market
segments and then make a choice that is
in the best interest of the community as
a whole and if you're consistent on that
you will win credibility over time but
almost by definition every decision we
make it's a little bit like politics
it's a little bit like being a mayor
that you know some of the people some of
the time will be really really angry
with you and the only thing you can do
is be incredibly transparent which is
here's the decision we made here's why
we made it and be incredibly transparent
and that gets us a long way you know
interestingly we still have site issues
today little ones but in the old days we
used to have big site issues and we had
a policy where we would within instance
post the issue that we had on the site
because the users often would have found
it before we did and if we posted and if
we were transparent we had huge
credibility so I think there's been a
few lessons learned here which is
transparency really doing it
consistently and giving sort of the
users the benefit of the doubt I think
has been part of the secret sauce